[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american docudrama
film called front of the class
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
twelve-year-old brad cohen has
tourette's syndrome because of the
condition he makes strange noises
twitches and yells randomly all these
actions are involuntary and brad has no
control over them but in the small town
in missouri most people are unfamiliar
with brad's unique syndrome they do not
believe him when he claims he cannot
stop the ticks even his father norman
thinks his son is making the noise just
to trouble his parents brad's classmates
bully him often and the teachers are of
no help the ticks started when he was
six years old around the time brad's
parents were getting divorced ever since
his mother has taken him to several
doctors all of whom who have associated
his tics with depression that is why the
real cause has never been diagnosed and
people continue to believe he is just a
spoiled brat brad's only friend is his
younger brother jeff although they fight
and bicker all the time brad feels like
jeff is the only person who gets him
their father norman lives in another
city and visits them once in a while he
connects with jeff but brad has always
been sort of an embarrassment for him he
often scolds the kids to stop yelling
and moving so much his father's distrust
in him makes brad feel like a failure
meanwhile brad's mother ellen has always
been supportive of her son she believes
him when he says the texts are not
something he can control ellen is
troubled by her friends and relatives
suggesting different absurd methods to
discipline her kid although she trusts
brad being a single mother with two kids
one of whom cannot stop yelling is
tiring for her one day she takes brad to
a new therapist in town the man asks him
about his parents divorce and its effect
on his life brad simply tells him that
he doesn't remember much about the
incident and it doesn't bother him at
all the doctor refuses to believe that
and claims that brad is in denial of the
effect which might be causing the ticks
he is yet again misdiagnosed and told
that the ticks will go away once he
disciplines himself the only time norman
feels proud of being brad's father is
when brad plays baseball in the field
everyone makes noises and moves which
makes brad feel like it's the only place
he fits however after every match norman
brings his sons home immediately to not
embarrass himself in front of the other
fathers sometimes the constant moving
and twitching makes norman lose his
temper he often lashes out at brad
unaware that he cannot stop them brad
usually gets good grades and is
excellent at studying however trying to
concentrate on exams brings out the
worst in him the stress makes his text
frequent and uncontrollable one day his
science teacher brings him to the
principal's office for the hundredth
time for the same reason the principal
calls his mother and agrees to give brad
the last chance to stop his mischievous
behavior ellen insists that her son
cannot help it but the principal in turn
calls her a bad parent for making
excuses for brad's bad behavior having
had enough of everyone blaming her son
ellen takes it upon herself to find out
the real cause of his symptoms she does
extensive research on conditions that
cause people to yell and twitch in the
end she comes across tourette's syndrome
brad finally has a way to prove that he
is not lying or being mischievous his
therapist is also told about the
discovery and he praises ellen for her
great work however the joy of finding
out the problem vanishes when ellen
realizes that the condition has no cure
her son will have to learn to live with
the noises the twitches and the
attention that comes with it still the
saddest person to find out about brad's
condition is his father norman he is
guilt-ridden that he never believed his
son but more than that he is distressed
that the kid might not have a good
future although the cure is impossible
ellen is determined to teach her kid to
live with tourettes one day she takes
him to a support group for people with
the same syndrome as him meeting them
was supposed to make brad feel better
but it makes him feel quite the opposite
he feels like he's seeing himself from
other people's eyes and he doesn't like
the view moreover he finds out that
everyone in the room has given up on
their lives the kids are homeschooled
while the adults get work from home type
jobs the experience is awful for brad
but it is also the defining moment in
his life starting that day he makes it
his mission to not be like the people
from the support group he promises to be
his own person and never let the
disability hold him back even after he
changes schools in 7th grade not much
progress is seen in how people treat him
the teachers always send him to the
principal and the classmates make fun of
him that is until the principal finds
out about brad's condition and invites
him to the stage during a school program
brad is asked to explain his syndrome to
the audience and explain what they can
do to help after finding out that he
actually cannot help but make the noises
people start being more sympathetic
towards him his life is never the same
again the principal becomes the one
teacher who helps him with his biggest
problem with ease and simplicity this
makes brad realize that he also wants to
be a teacher like him in the future time
flies by and brad soon grows into a
handsome young man with a bachelor's
diploma in education he moves to atlanta
and gets an apartment with a roommate
hoping to land a teaching job the
officer at the state education board is
impressed by his qualification however
she is skeptical if teaching would be a
suitable profession for someone with
tourette's not just her but most people
brad knows think the same about his
choice of profession he understands
their concerns to some level but he
knows in his heart that he was born to
teach the very next day he goes to his
first job interview his tics visibly
bother the interviewer but he is not
ashamed or uncomfortable to explain his
condition he also makes sure to assure
the man that his tics are an open topic
for the students to discuss and it won't
harm their studies in any way but the
interviewer doesn't seem convinced in
the end he is white listed the same
thing happens at the next interview and
the one after that he uses several
different methods like talking about his
texts for the entire interview or not
acknowledging them at all but none of
them land him the job to take his mind
off of things his roommate sets him up
on a blind date he meets a girl at a bar
and is instantly attracted to her the
only problem arises when people around
them stare at them because of brad's
tics by the end of the night his date is
visibly uncomfortable to be seen with
him it turns out that brad has never
landed a second date with any woman he
still hopes that one day he will find
someone who can see him past his ticks
brad's father owns a construction
business in atlanta and is ready to help
him with money until he gets a job but
brad doesn't want to accept favors from
norman the man still thinks that brad
cannot survive as a teacher and voices
that opinion every chance he gets after
25 failed attempts at job interviews
brad has a mental breakdown in his car
he feels hopeless and broken but after
talking to his mother over the phone he
realizes that the ticks aren't the
reason for his failure he just hasn't
found the right school for the 26th
interview he goes to an elementary
school the principal and vice principal
are already well informed about
tourette's syndrome and do not make brad
feel uncomfortable by treating him any
differently the interview goes on for
two hours and is the best one he has
ever had by now brad has learned to not
have high hopes but still he cannot help
but wish to get the job to his surprise
the next day he is called to teach
second graders he is over the moon at
the news although he only has two days
to prepare for the class he couldn't
care less about the time and is excited
to finally get to teach his fellow
teachers welcome him and help him set up
in the classroom for the first time in
his life brad finds people who do not
judge him for his tics at night he calls
his mother who pressures him into dating
a woman brad takes her advice and meets
a tinder date named nancy the next day
the two immediately hit it off but brad
feels like he'll be ignored after the
first date like he always has following
the fun date they separate with a simple
goodbye later brad gets an email from
her praising his taste in music he gets
the hint and invites nancy on a second
date the next day is his first day as a
teacher initially the children laugh at
his tics but then he explains to them
what tourette's syndrome is and what it
does to people even the second graders
seem to be understanding after finding
out brad cannot control the noises they
ask him several questions all of which
he answers happily by the end of the day
the kids love him but the same cannot be
said for the parents when they come to
pick their children up they seem to not
like the new teacher brad senses this
but is confident that they will like him
after getting to know him better
meanwhile he continues dating nancy and
starts falling in love for the first
time she genuinely doesn't seem to care
about his tics and likes him for his
personality in school brad bonds with a
cheerful little girl named heather she
is the smartest one in the class but it
is her kindness that catches his
attention when the other kids make fun
of brad she shuts them down some parents
request their kids to not be in brad's
class because of his disability the
school allows it but brad is asked to
keep his head up because the parents are
the hardest part of the job one
afternoon after school heather comments
that she is about to lose her hair her
mother confirms that the little girl has
cancer and is undergoing chemo even
still the chances of her survival are
very low the news saddens brad to his
core the mother also adds that heather
cannot wait to come to school nowadays
he is the only person keeping her happy
during the last few months of her life
the news only makes brad feel
bittersweet a few weeks later brad goes
to take a test for the master's degree
but isn't given a private room as
promised he talks to the administration
but they refuse to help him when he
starts to panic norman comes to his aid
and threatens to sue the administration
they eventually agree to let him take
the test in private the incident is a
bonding moment for the father and son in
the following scene we see nancy and
brad go to his mother's house for
thanksgiving seeing her socialize with
her family brad cannot help but to get
emotional he pulls nancy aside and
confesses his love for the first time
eventually heather stops coming to
school her classmates make letters and
postcards wishing her good health but
one day they get the news that they had
been dreading to hear at heather's
funeral brad refrains himself from going
inside thinking that he will disrupt the
ceremony but her mother thanks him for
being her daughter's sunshine in her
darkest days and invites him in a few
months later brad's life is running
smoothly he has a loving girlfriend a
good relationship with his father and a
job that he loves then one day he is
called to a school meeting and informed
that he is being awarded sally may's
first teacher of the year on the night
of the event brad gives a heartfelt
speech that everyone loves the movie
ends with a message that we should never
let any obstacle stop us from pursuing
our dreams subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching